ben affleck and jennifer lopez are
moving in together and a source is
opening up to e.t about life together
under the same roof
baby you're my shelter
shelter from a broken
paradise i couldn't dream it any better
if i tried
bennifer 2.0 recently purchased a 50
million mansion in bel air the source
says the pair wants a house together in
la and probably a couple of other places
as well but this house in bel air is key
for a couple of reasons quote they spend
every night together when they can and
having this home will make that easier
it's the next step in their relationship
and since they are both in it for the
long run they can't wait to have a home
together it's exciting it's exciting and
ben and jen who rekindled their romance
in 2021 have plans to make the home
their own the source adds the lovebirds
are planning to decorate and renovate it
together so it'll be 100 their place and
as far as the decor goes turns out jlo
is taking the lead
but the source explains that they want
to implement both of their styles so
everyone feels comfortable moving into
the house and this new chapter in all
their lives i have nothing to complain
about now this new bel air home should
be big enough for ben and jen's blended
families of course the selena star
shares 14 year old twins max and emmy
with her ex mark anthony while the actor
and his ex jennifer gardner are parents
to 16 year old violet 13 year old
seraphina and 10 year old samuel and
with all those kids running around it
turns out it hasn't been so easy to have
some alone time bathroom yeah is that
where you go
yeah yeah yeah all right his is moments
what's that for private moments to have
talks to do things yeah that's where you
go
but one thing's for sure j.lo and ben
are excited to bring their kiddos along
in this next chapter it's just a dream
come true the source tells et that at
this point they know they are meant to
be together and will bring everyone
together as one big unit it will be
great for the kids and everyone is
excited and can't wait to get even
closer the source adds the couple also
can't wait to make new memories in their
new home and host fun events like
birthdays and holidays i don't think
anybody was more surprised than us yeah
no but it is no seriously though i mean
that's just would you ever have imagined
that it comes full circle it ends up
like no you you never could imagine
something like that could happen
it's a beautiful thing
[Music]